so this is you can think of as the baby
Jessica right when baby Jessica fell to
the well and she really suffered and her
parents must have been incredibly
miserable she got more CNN coverage in
Rwanda in Darfur right and the question
is why why does this happen and and why
do people care so much and it turns out
is the research on what's called the
identifiable victim effect and the
question is if you have how many lives
are at stake and how much do we care you
would expect that as more lives are at
stake we would care more maybe in a
linear relationship or maybe we would
care more in the beginning and it'll be
kind of a diminishing return like we
wouldn't care if it's a hundred or a
thousand but we care a lot at the bottom
range but it turns out the function is
different we care a lot about individual
life and you care less and less is that
pi is the number of people become bigger
and this goes to kind of an observation
is both Stalin and Mother Teresa said
Stalin said one death is a tragedy a
million death is a statistic and mother
Teresa said in the same spirit if I look
at the masses I will never act if I look
at the one I will and both of them
basically portray this idea that what
happened when we kind of think about
recruiting ourselves to act against
something it's not about our mind
thinking it's not about the cold
calculated thought about what's
worthwhile what's the cost-benefit
analysis
it's about our heart it's about our
emotions and the question is what can
activate emotion and it turns out that
an individual case can get us to care
versus a a big set of cases just become
statistics so this beautiful results by
a Deb small and George Lowenstein and
Paul slovic that basically say here is
one girl in Africa who is hungry how
much money would you give her and then
two other people they say here's the
problem of hunger in Africa there are
three million kids in Sudan and there
are five million kids here and this how
much money would you give and people
give half as much to Africa then they
give to the single girl Rokia it
actually gets worse because you said if
people give more when it's emotional
than when it's statistical what happens
when we give both information but say
hey here's one girl Rokia think you see
how sad she is and how much money could
help her by the way there's five million
more like her what would happen it goes
down it turns out that every time you
activate cognition calculation
thoughtfulness you turn off the emotion
people care less and give much less and
of course this explains a little bit
they kind of imbalance between what we
give to and what we don't give to so
think about how difficult it is to get
money for prevention of diseases
prevention of malaria or prevention of
diarrhea or deworming kids in the world
you know lots of kids have have worms it
turns out that those things are
incredibly important incredibly useful
you can actually get people to be much
much healthier but it's not motivating
right deworming a kids or you know
million kids in India just doesn't make
you feel woman on fuzzy or preventing
kids in the future from getting malaria
is again not that exciting but if you
can help one person specific concrete
get something we all get very excited
from it so there is a real imbalance
between what really matters and what we
care about and what we give our time and
money to
if you run enough for profit of course
you want to build on these on this
irrationalities because you care about
your not-for-profit and i think the
example here is of course the American
Cancer Society they've done a really
good job first of all the word cancer is
great in in a money recruiting way right
it's an it's an awful disease the second
thing is the word survivor is really
good
and the third thing they do is they
create an incredible fear from cancer I
mean the truth is we all have lots of
cancer and we all usually get get over
it I mean some some people of course
don't but in our lifetime will all have
cancerous cells and in most cases it
will be just part of the deal of living
and but but they create is these really
negative association that now everybody
who had cancer even if it was not
malignant and will not cause them to die
or it was so slow it will take 50 years
to develop and they call everybody a
cancer survivor and because of that
everybody who knows them and everybody
who cares about them start caring about
about cancer now you know it's kind of
interesting because they've basically
have mastered this issue right they've
mastered making it central focal created
very strong fear about about cancer and
in caring about it and they basically
get a lot of money and if you look at
them as a non-for-profit they are an
incredibly wealthy not-for-profit in
fact other not-for-profits feel that the
Cancer Society is getting so much money
that people just don't give to other
causes because they give so much to that
cause and now there's all kinds of
movements to basically stop their
statuses and on for profit because
they're so wealthy and they spend so
much money on salaries and and so on but
but in a sense of understanding human
psychology they're the top basically